bonjour venez vite juliette avec les
enfants qui ont apporté des objets
formidables qu'ils ont fabriqué
eux-mêmes qu'un clou et qu'est-ce que tu
apportes walhalla elle arrive les bras
chargés tire bien que noël 6 et des
tapisseries magnifique avec couleur vous
regarde casimir tiens moi sa rue on les
voit bien c'est dans ce sens là ray au
nom et à l'envers tu veux explique alors
comment tu fais ça chloé d'abord enfin
le dessin la peinture
oui on prend une plaque en bois à une
fille qui est des clous en train de
lalaye à wil hahn qu'elle a appris en
trois mi-temps gloire ce jeu c'est avec
une épingle à cheveux tu t'y ce qu'elle
fait là celle-là c'est un modèle sais
quoi est une maison
oui et et le soleil là c'est très très
beau alors philippe tu m'apportes encore
d'autres choses
les gravures les gravures elles sont
elles aussi dit danse et des
chefs-d'oeuvre sur chef-d'oeuvre mais tu
méritais comme on fait ça elles sont
toutes plus belles les unes que les
autres si jamais ça oui
abc le modèle ça et après on prend une
fois que le dessin est bien fait qu'on a
une idée on prend une phrase un lino et
puis on commence à graver le dessin du
rhin le leem au congrès sur des coups
avec dégoût et on grave le dessin et une
fois grave et après on passe d d encre
exemple en amont sur le fond même si des
encres verte
et puis après on passe sous une presse
ou même papier dessus on passe une fête
après presque on passe avec une cuillère
ouais et puis donc c'est comme ça à mes
d'accord et puis après on en tire il
mardi soir autant qu'on veut mais moi
oui une fois que tu as un modèle comme
ça tu peux tirer le nombre d'exemplaires
que tu veux très trop au fur et à mesure
l'encours souvient peut donc changer de
couleur voilà a très bien et en panne
avec ses peintures les pales pure on
court maintenant on l'a dit dont casimir
tu sais qu'on déborde on croule sous les
affaires tu pourrais peut-être nous les
parents pour les peintures accrochées
qui va m'aider à nathan lands et des
tables où ça c'est des aquarelles on va
les accrocher la roue
oui c'est tu devrais
là dessus il ya aussi toujours des
couleurs remarquables
j'en appelle à l'envers mais bien avant
lui mais avec des pincettes
pascal tu viens qu'est-ce que tu
m'apportes toi une exposition qu'est ce
que c'est un vitrail
mais ça c'est une autre projet de
vitrail alors comment tu fais ça je
cherche je cherche des des expressions
de litres al oui et puis après je je
prends le papier ouais je fais des
dessins de peintures que je colorie et
que après je prends du papier et je le
jeu les découper des morceaux et je le
colle sur la peinture
l'accord est alors après c'est ça c'est
la maquette et après on réalise le
vitrail comme ça
voilà qui réalise et du monde sur une
échelle versailles les plus grands oui
là tu as fait un projet de vie très
tabou et harry d'accord très très bien
et encore ne gagne qui arrive avec une
oeuvre plus grosse tél ça c'est un
panneau magali ce qui est fait sur tissu
vieille un temps valérie tient lui son
panneau pour qu'elle vienne nous
expliquer comment ça se fait un chêne
contes arctiques hommes
pour la tapisserie j'ai fait une vie
sont un pur oui et après on a pris mon
cadeau je les pique si derrière pour
info de modèles j'ai passé de la burqa
pourtant pas trop que ça dépend bah oui
c'est ça pour pas qu'ils aient des
bavures de riches et j'ai peine à vis
des actions spéciales
oui c'est des fleurs que tu as voulu
représenter c'est un jardin imaginaire
c'est très très beau qu'est ce que
j'aimerais qu'on voit là ils sont tous
plus forts les uns que les autres
mais vous savez quel serait mon rêve à
moi ce serait d'être peintre serbie
tableau comme vous comme certains
d'entre vous mais je crois qu'il serait
très nettement moins bon que vous voulez
écouter
[Musique]
beaucoup de couleurs
avec beaucoup de douceur
je voudrais faire
montrer
[Musique]
j'ai des garçons
casimir show de sa chance
françois
vos jeux
[Musique]
mais je ne vais mieux pas si je vais à
fond mais j'aimerais mieux peu si
j'étais un enfant
[Musique]
dans le client que les [ __ ] et
on développe les colis
couleur cerise seront ré écran
m
un papillon passants
ainsi sur un nombre à deux
utilisez vous
[Musique]
oui je m'en fais mieux si je désire la
fin je leur ai mieux peu si j'étais à
londres
[Musique]